another encouraging video we could play
for you this is from fox it says a 14
year old in virginia is speaking out
about what she says is a sexist move by
the loudoun county public schools to
allow boys into girls locker rooms
the policy followed a previous um a
previous one that committed
the the county to providing an equitable
safe and inclusive working environment
regardless of sexual orientation
or gender identity and other individual
characteristics
the more recent proposed policy states
in a draft
that students should be allowed to use
the facility that corresponds to their
gender identity
now we've seen a lot we've seen a lot of
videos from school board meetings
especially
loudoun county where they've they've
really been fighting this out
but i wanted to show you this this is
jolene grover
who got up and spoke and she's wearing a
shirt that reads woman is female
so she is answering my
infamous question what is a woman she
has an answer for and i like her answer
i also like everything else she has to
say here let's listen
two years ago i was told policy 1040 was
just an umbrella philosophy
and you weren't going to allow boys into
the girls locker rooms but here you are
doing just that everyone knows what a
boy is even you
your proposed policies are dangerous and
rooted in sexism
when woe kids asked me if i was a
lesbian or a trans boy because i cut my
hair short
it should tell you these modern
identities are superficial
my guidance counselor's response to my
concerns about bathroom privacy and
safety was
well there are stalls in the bathrooms
now boys are reading erotica in the
classrooms next to girls
and you want to give them access to
girls locker rooms and you want to force
girls to call those boys she you do this
in the name of inclusivity while
ignoring the girls who will pay the
price
your policies choose boys wants over
girls needs
here is what do we say 14 year old girl
an eighth grader and she's teaching
these adults
about basic biological science
now we need children to stand up and
tell adults and speak
common sense to adults educate them
what's the i go back to again
why send your kid into an environment
where they're going to have to teach
the teachers you're not even sending
your kids into school to be taught
anymore
they have to be the ones doing the
educating now
the teachers are the ones in school they
have to have to learn about these things
and so here's just one now we don't
often hear
and this will be something that's often
pointed out by the left
that you know we don't often hear
a lot of young girls standing up
in front of microphones and speaking out
against this kind of thing and actually
saying i don't want boys in the locker
room with me
we don't hear it that often why don't we
hear it
it's because they they're all okay with
it is it because none of them
value their privacy
no it's because they're kids and most
kid
forget about kids most people most
adults don't have the courage to do
what jolene grover did just there
especially
kids don't have it and the difference
between kids and adults as far as echoes
is kids have an excuse
because they're just kids and they
shouldn't be put in this situation to
begin with
i mean kids should not be in a situation
where they have to stand up and actually
explain
why they don't want boys in the girls
locker room
so i don't blame the kids who remain
silent in that situation
but most do because they're afraid
obviously i mean this this whole idea
that
well the kids aren't complaining most of
them anyway and the ones who do
they're bigots mostly kids aren't
complaining so sure they must be fine
with it
oh obviously this is a view held by
any rational person
and the kids who don't feel that way
it's because they've been berated
into believing that they're not supposed
to feel that way
think about the situation a lot of these
young girls are in they're made to feel
guilty for wanting privacy if they if
they want
basic privacy and security the basic
privacy security
that we all had in school and growing up
and it was never an issue we never
never had to even think about it
right if you were a girl growing up and
going to school in the 90s
you went into your locker room there was
no notion that any guys would be in
there and if they did
they'd be tossed out and suspended
so that was something you had that was
something we all had didn't have to
think about
and now it's an issue and i think there
are a lot of kids also that are being
they're they're being psychologically
beaten down and indoctrinated
and they have this obviously natural
desire for privacy and security like
anybody else would but now they're made
to believe that that is it's somehow
bigoted and they have to resist that
within themselves
that it's their fault the problem is on
them
that's what they're telling girls so
it's saying to like
13 year old girls in a locker room if
this boy comes in
and you don't like it you're the problem
you are the problem there is something
wrong with
you not him or her quote unquote
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now
i thank you for your compliance it is
somewhat appreciated